Bất đường buổi khẩm lộ cao hàng trục mẹ quận qua khác bị tần,
kính bầu trời đối sâm trị trong bài phút.
Theo CCTV, Siddier Sây ra khoảng 0,000 mẹ bảo ngay bảo ngay bố tấn lâm tại các mỹ tần
đồng phạt trung quốc, tính gặng hiệp trường cho hay,
phối bột đồng đồng từ xa quốc lượng, dành trống bảo vụ các khu dân cử và nhiều chuyến phố.
Nguyên đi đường và tìm lơi trua anh, tâm dình tại một số quốc vực giảm xuống dưới một chăm mẹ.
Theo Trái Nào Weather, tư mấy bẩy đến mùa tắm giờ,
nhiều nơi ở đồng bắt chúng quốc kỳ nhận gió dạc cấp tắm đến mười.
Dương tại các nghĩ tần có nơi xuất hiện gió dạc tới 1,5 mẹ trên dợi
tư đường của bởi 2.
Gió mạnh khiến nhiều kê sành bật bất, sẽ cộ hương hạc,
và một số công tyng ngoài trời bị ai cơm.
Được được trức năng sau đó được vi đợp gió kê gãi, các phục hiện trường.
Cơ quan ý tưởng Trung Quốc cho biết trước khi bảo vụ xuất hiện,
các nghĩ tần bởi trải qua một ngày đáng 9 giếm gặp,
với nhận đội vượt 8.0 đồ xe,
khi với công ty nạn chàn xuống từ phía thời,
chính lạc nhận độ lưỡin tạo ra đối lụ mạnh,
kéo theo dân, zón dẫn, và quân lượng lưỡin tổ thô và thầy phố.